thank you
uh the 49ers linebacker all Pro-Line
Packer he is uh Fred Warner who joins us
on behalf of X Tech shoulder pads the
latest pad technology celebrating its 10
years on the field go to xtechpads.com
or at X techpads on Instagram let's say
hello to the great Niners linebacker
Fred Warner
let's go let's go
he's got the pads on I like that come on
guys all right looks good thank you
thank you I had to come out ready it
looks like you're ready to hit somebody
there Fred I mean who wants it
I would do that too I wouldn't do that
to you yeah uh it's good to see you yeah
good to be here thank you we have one
49er fan on our staff or just one yeah
all right yeah I mean had you beaten the
Eagles you might have had a few more but
so so Marvin is a 49er fan lifelong fan
I love and I gave him a chance to ask
Debo yesterday or two days ago uh a
question okay any did Horrible no yeah
he did horrible oh he stammered
stuttered didn't really ask a question
all right would you say it's a fair
assessment Marshall first of all
first wasn't on that uh on that poll
question of what I would say first but
look oh look look is what I said you
were going to start with friends no no I
said first first was the first word okay
Debo wasn't the most uh talkative okay
right so Dan was asking questions mark
do you have a question he didn't want to
answer your questions why would he want
to answer my questions
because you didn't understand he got to
answer your questions you the Niner fan
yeah but he didn't seem like he wasn't
talking okay more about just you know
Towing The Rock and running people over
that's okay all right that's his yeah
all right Marv you're stolen no no you
interrupted me all right all right okay
three two one
here's the big question oh
do you guys ever feel like you guys have
true Road games because Niner fans
travel everywhere my boys went to a game
in Atlanta and they said it felt like a
home game it felt like San Francisco
when you guys were out there I might be
biased but I think we have the best fans
in the league no you're right you're
right uh we call them the faithful
because they they truly they're there no
matter what
um you know it does feel like a home
game especially when we go down Play La
you know that's that's our Stadium it's
like we're just getting next to the home
game every season but uh uh yeah no
that's the best fans in the league all
right let's say goodbye to Fred Warner
that's the only reason why we're having
them on thank you Fred just one question
I'm from Connecticut and we just got
tons of Connecticut uh Niners fans so
big fans that's it you had one question
that's it oh but the entire time oh he's
gonna mess it up oh Marvin wrong okay
you did ask a question that was close
ended you didn't say why are the Niners
fans the best in the NFL hmm
because you were like going hey you know
Niner fans and and I had a friend who
said when they went to Atlanta and then
so you just say why do the Niners have
the the best besides besides La okay
what was the game where you felt like
man there's more Niners fans
Marv no no you had one shot that's it
and I asked it and he answered I know
but I mean it wasn't a great question
you guys had a great question let's
bring back the Niners Fred Warner who
joins us on the program yes great to see
you friend thank you for playing along
the pleasure to be here seriously great
coverage linebacker I do all right
you're okay with that yeah I do okay
okay well I I was saying to Debo I
thought you were underrated and he goes
no he's not and then I went okay
nationally I think you are
do you okay do you feel it almost feels
like you got to sack somebody or have
interceptions to get any kind of
recognition yeah I mean I probably
wouldn't know the difference if I was
nationally known or not you know because
I don't pay attention to it much but
you're right I mean the sacks the
interceptions those like the flat the
splash plays that's something that you
know people uh kind of know players for
more
um I feel like down in and down out
there's nobody better explain to me why
Travis Kelsey is always open
um
I don't know that's a good question but
he is he doesn't strike me as being
fast
or quick sneaky fast he's sneaky quick
okay but I don't know he's just he's
just a big body he's obviously played
the game a long time now he's Savvy with
with the way that he runs his routes you
know you gotta double him you know
that's just kind of that's just who he
is that's where he's at in his in his
career right now where he's that good
you gotta double him and the teams that
don't it's like
what are you doing you know I see guys
put DNS on him uh you know stand up DNS
trying to put it put him on him in
coverage uh you know you got you got
your DBS and linebackers it's kind of a
mismatch no matter who you put on them
yeah the best tight end you've you've
faced in your careers who
probably every day I practice George
Kittle yeah yeah
is he calculated or crazy a little bit
is he both yeah a little bit of both
yeah yeah if people knew George Moore
like there's more to him than just being
like a psycho you know like
everybody you know sees like the Joker
and you know having the having fun but
like I mean there's there's real depth
to him like in the way that he
approaches the game and
um you know he hands out these little
these little cards that have sayings on
sayings on them
um you know and like like the real deal
for sure he's like a kid yeah a lot of
times but like a kid who's had a lot of
candy
he just kind of wild out there there's a
lot of energy yeah too much candy
although Debo when he was on did say
you're the one guy in practice who
doesn't take a play off and never it's
always a hundred percent man was Debo
talking about me the whole interview a
little bit he didn't want to talk about
him and he didn't want to talk about the
quarterbacking situation so I'm like uh
understandably yeah I I did ask him I
said who do you want as the quarterback
and what did he say he took a drink of
water
he didn't say
okay anything you don't have any water
who do you want is the quarterback now
I'm not the one catching the passes you
know if Diva if anybody was going to
answer the question it got to be Debo no
but you're on the sidelines and you're
hoping that offense scores some points
absolutely so you're not you're not
lying about that I want whoever's going
to give us the best chance to win okay
did you see this from Brock Purdy in PR
be honest yeah during the course of the
year before he took over
did you know how did you view Brock
Purdy
um I
I was a fan of his and you can ask
anybody in the facility anybody in that
in that building like I was a fan of his
day one I can ask anybody anybody
anybody yeah all right I was a fan like
Sarah who is the receptionist if I Said
Fred Warner she's like wait did you know
that Fred would like walk by and be
talking about Brock Purdy under his
breath like well I don't know what I
don't know what the problem is but I
mean come on like what's up with them
but the once you saw Christian McCaffrey
go into the game
[Laughter]
that we were getting Chris McCaffrey I'm
at my house getting my hair cut and my
barber he's a huge Niner fan shout out
Jr and uh he's he's cutting my hair and
he gets an alert on his phone he's like
bro you guys just got Chris McCaffrey
I'm like no no he did it man what are
you talking about and he's like yes bro
look it's on ESPN and we're both going
crazy like we're in the house jumping up
and down like you know obviously that's
like as big of a Blog but blockbuster
trade as it comes but when he goes into
the game
your Johnson goes down rock goes down
and you see Krista McCaffrey is your
quarterback yeah he's got the armband on
and you're thinking what
oh boy
you know
um yeah dude it was as crazy of a
situation as I just felt so unfair yeah
because even you know deebles said ayuk
was wide open on the play that uh that
he that Brock got hurt yeah so he
probably would have thrown a touchdown
pass probably in that situation yeah I
mean it's so tough to look back like and
be like Oh Coulda Shoulda Woulda and
what could have happened and stuff it
is honestly like the worst luck that we
could have had you're gonna watch the
Super Bowl yeah watch
do you care
do I care about who wins no
why are you watching because I'm a
football fan you know I'm I I live and
breathe it you know this is my thing so
I'm gonna watch yeah see that would be
tough but you can't root for the Eagles
so yeah I'm not rooting for either team
no don't give me don't get me wrong like
I dislike both teams obviously now
because there's there's there's Rich
history now between obviously losing to
the though both teams in uh big time
games but yeah no I mean the Super Bowl
is the Super Bowl
um it does hurt you know being here
hurts I remember I was I was over by the
stadium yesterday and kind of seeing it
all dressed up
um you know for the longest time like I
was that was my mindset was I was going
to be here you know Super Bowl 57
February 12th like had it written down
you know and obviously not to be in it
it sucks he just said Fred Warner the
Niners linebacker two-time All-Pro I
have this suggestion for the Pro Bowl
that if you're going to put it on your
resume sure you only get the initial
vote
that said that you're a pro bowl not an
alternate oh alternate doesn't get to go
on your resume okay because you know yet
Tyler Huntley who got to go to the Pro
Bowl right and he threw two he threw two
more touchdowns than I did this year
Fred I understand so I think it should
be just that first team that's announced
then you can put it on your resume
everybody else is just somebody who is a
uh added to the roster competing at the
uh the Pro Bowl festivity that's an
interesting take I think I think there
should be something next to your name
even if you are an alternate but there
should be like a distinction right
because right now there's no distinction
of like if you were the initial pro bowl
or if you were an alternate you know
there should be kind of like a a
distinction you know next to your name
if you are do you get anything for being
all pro
um
more money in your contract oh
do you have bonuses in there for all no
no no no bonus I'm talking about like
when you come to the table like that's
that's obviously a nice thing to have
but they don't give you a plaque or
anything or I don't know jacket or a
sweatshirt or football or they just give
you a tweet on Twitter that's it saying
you you made it yeah uh who do you
pattern your game after
uh Bobby Wagner oh yeah no when I was in
college at BYU that's the only guy I
watched I mean he was the he was the
model of what you know what it is to
play Mike backer in this league when I
was coming out
um you know and then obviously when I
got drafted to the Niners seeing him
twice a year and watching him even more
closely and then becoming friends
exchanging numbers and like now he's
like a big brother to me like him made
it like I could text him and he'll
respond back and let me know whatever
how cool is that though so if I would
have told you in college by the way
kidding me that dude is going to be a
mentor he's going to be your buddy I'd
have never believed it a lot of the
things I see these days I mean I was
back at the Pro Bowl last week Ray Lewis
52 comes grabs me he's like hey starts
starts giving me game like just talking
to me on the side about what I need to
do with my past coverage and and all
these type of things and I'm like this
is Ray Lewis like are you kidding me
like
bro hey come on like this is surreal so
uh you know stuff like that I get I get
Star Struck all the time pain Manning's
in in the locker room before you know we
were warming up are you getting pictures
with these guys I'll show you right now
I got a picture with Peyton in the
locker did you get one with Ray oh see I
don't think I got one with Ray no maybe
somebody took a picture I think there's
there's plenty of pictures places
because I don't know what's cool or not
like would you exchange jerseys with
like a quarterback
in the league right that's playing right
now yeah absolutely have you done that
um I don't think so I really wanted to
ask Tom Brady for his but I'm like I was
kind of what you know what you guys were
all getting in line to get the green law
green logs it looked like an autograph
so
so Dave Tom's here to sign autographs
come on guys I know so like you guys
were all geeking out I'm like this
probably isn't the best time to have the
first jersey or demanding signatures on
the interception balls you know so I'm
like probably not the best timing I I
think he was so surprised that he that's
why he signed it yeah because he was
like wait wait what and then I think
he's done it before and he's probably
used to it by now we usually do that in
private yeah you don't do that out on
the field and he was mic'd up so like
you could see the whole interaction it's
all it's on camera yeah did you give him
a hard time for asking Brady for his
autograph oh no I'm the one who who told
him to do it oh you did we're on the
sideline we're on the sideline and I'm
sitting there you know we've been pulled
out of the game at this point we're
blowing him out and I'm like are you
gonna get your ball signed by Tom Brady
he's like nah probably my boat how do
you like we don't know when the next
time we're gonna play this guys you need
to you need to do it you're responsible
for this we we talked about it and we I
rolled up there with him to make sure he
wasn't out there alone you know it was a
great moment seriously oh you know how
many times can you ask somebody like
that Hall of Famer the goat and then the
goat you got it you got a uh seeing them
up close like like this this microphone
is him and this is me like we're this
close you know it was but during the
game did you hit him
I think I got I think I got a little I
got a little hit on him okay one time
but you can't hit him too I think it was
actually like this oh you just tapped
him just tapped yeah you just gotta tap
him like as he's going down you give him
a little tap you know you don't want a
flag or nothing so uh and he likes to
yell back at you yeah you know what he
didn't do that it didn't matter at that
point probably he only yelled back when
you're winning and uh they weren't
winning uh tell me about the uh X Tech
pads uh that you have because it's
amazing when you look at the old like
NFL films and guys had these big pads
now huge pads like you guys it just look
like pop warner my my coach Johnny
Holland he played way back in the day he
shows highlights of these humongous pads
on and I think that's the best part
about our game now is we've evolved into
just you know X Tech these pads that you
you don't even feel like you have them
on when I'm out there that's like the
number one thing for a linebacker is
your shoulder pads right because I'm
delivering hits living blows and you
want something that has protection and
performance you know something that you
can when you're running around it feels
like you have nothing on and you watch
you watch Dance With Honors last like
are some of the highlights some of the
highlights you guys watch
yeah so the offense Player of the Year
defense player of the year Justin
Jefferson Nick Bosa like these are the
top guys in the league and they all wear
these pads you know myself Josh Jacobs
who's one of the he's you know in my
opinion the best running back in the
league this past season he wears these
pads and we all wear them because of the
performance and we know that we're going
to be protected out there on the field
all the top colleges high schools they
wear them and uh you know I think they
do a great job Bob over here he's on the
side he came to the 49ers
and fitted me my first year my you know
when I was a little pup uh coming out of
BYU fitting me with custom pads and I
you know I still
um I'm rocking X Tech because I believe
in them did you bring enough for all of
us
um I don't know do we have some we got
some on the side we can run one-on-one
drills right here on this little this
little green mat that we got on the
ground are you could you take all four
of my guys
right now
um four on one is maybe okay yeah
we can try okay
I did my stretches this morning does
anybody come up to you and want you to
hit them no not at all they're smarter
than that
we're not
here
um hey congrats on the season obviously
didn't end the way you thought but uh
great to have you on thank you man I
appreciate it and Marvin yeah
[Applause]
we're gonna take a break by the way if
you uh want to stick around we have food
coming off the Traeger grill over there
are you kidding me we we cooked a hog
all night long really yeah we had people
sleep here last night all right and they
they had the Traeger grill on and they
cooked a whole hog wow so if you'd like
to have some food we'll pull it off the
grill I'd you know it'd be my pleasure
he is Fred Warner of the Niners the X
Tech shoulder pads you can go to
xtechpads.com or at X text uh pads on
Instagram take it back a break we'll
close up shop after this on The Dan
Patrick Show